do you remember this the Connors want
the lottery on the original Roseanne
back in 1996 and now the spin-off is a
big winner because it's TV's number one
new comedy yeah and two huge stars are
joining the family the season with
Juliette Lewis making her debut tonight
David told me you probably upset come
here don't touch me
we shot the first one I could not
believe how homey it felt on set and
just comfortable Juliette posted these
pics from the Conner set she plays
David's girlfriend Blu and she's at odds
with his ex Darlene as soon as you found
out this happened you should have called
me I don't have a cell phone they kill
bees
okay I'm sorry see I didn't realize
you're out of your mind
Juliette's pal Sarah Gilbert is also an
executive producer but I've known Sarah
Gilbert for really long time and our
dynamic of the shows is pretty funny the
recurring guest spot is a reunion of
sorts for Juliet and on screen love
Johnny Galecki they were siblings in
1989's National Lampoon's Christmas
vacation tonight also marks his first
appearance on the Connors I love that
you guys were able to work it out and
come back it wouldn't have been the same
it's purely due to how supportive my
bigbang family is here so I'm very
grateful and that's not all Justin Long
makes his guest starring debut tonight -
as Darlene's new love interest a lot of
times if you're doing a sitcom you don't
always get the level of actors that we
get but I think because people are fans
of the show so we've just been very
fortunate oh we're gonna see more
romance soon this time for Laurie
Metcalf Jackie when Matthew Broderick
joins the show as her love interest
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]